bene di ragazzi perché quando con pietro
che ancora questo nostro parkour è
preferibile visione ragazze
devo farlo in terza persona nostra
grosso per pure tu non è che se io provo
a prendere cose lo slavo perché erano
bene perché si può prendere anche quello
non lo so voglio proporre cioè sto
provando non io non è che saltato di
interesse ma io voglio andare su questo
nulla e li faccio questa ma pensaci
sempre bettarini che agli altri ce l'ho
fatta già fatta
mica che casino quami che vanno sì è
arrivato ho fatto 32 infatti ci dai
ma come fai qua c'è tutto un bordello
deve sinistra poi a destra ma lascerà
tutto c'erano idea di quanto era
difficile ho visto un livello pazzesco
vai ad essere molto ma ho capito sta
andando e difficile è fallo tu il primo
salto è proprio difficile mica poi gli
altri tutti facili tranquilla ma
parlarne ok ok
porca vacca no va bene va bene va bene
bene quali sono mia mamma mia ma scusami
ma li aspetta un attimo perché c'era ti
giuro che c'era un altro livello ma se
ci fosse non parla così accettare così è
servito sulla no secondo me no secondo
dami ingegnere fare che certo non è per
niente proprio tale anzi se fosse
ragioni ha tradito da fare così vai vai
ahimè non lo fare non lo fare piquet bra
prova picchiami rispetto questo è un
posto più carte mi dispiace saltare
picchiami e non ci arrivo non averne una
ma che mantiene fatto fatto fatto non
fatti picchiare
tranquillo non è un problema ormai chi
te lo faccio volentieri
hanno sbagliato ho sbagliato la quale di
fare una roba un po strano spiego
l'amica sul gas tratto si aspetta che
fanno veramente il castrato lo sa è sono
fatta mica ce l'ho fatta io mi sento
hanno chiamato incastrati quando vuoi
arrivederci salve a tutti happy qua
onesto allora quasi che non so che
potevo andare lentamente li madonna che
casi basta con le staccionate vi prego
il e odio le detesto cosa guardi vai
avanti
no per favore che ha già reso l'ansia
per questo anche noi non faccio nulla io
basta tirare uno schiaffo tranquillo
mammamia proprio lungo il proprio qui i
nomi che non finire il livello senza di
me amiche se non provare di semi guardia
basta che c'è un tasto schiacciato cosa
hai fatto
non lo so schiacciato qualcosa cosa che
fa vedi qualcosa
guardate in giro e un tasto e ma dov'è
che fa qualcosa valeva per le porte qui
sotto michele ma quali sotto quello di
ferro guardaci e nero attimo a 3000
premio dei premi lo ha fatto grazie ciao
e come cazzo faccio io è fuso gatti tuoi
vado per un attimo pensavo di non
riuscirci proprio ti giuro mi sono
caricato nelle mutande da vino è stato è
stato bello che bisogna fare è bastato
dire così bellissimo giovato affronta
nice
in questa difficile invece buono o le è
proprio lui secondo subito l'impegno
minchiam in che due bellissime prove
probabili aspetta aspetta mario cal che
dona la meta che da caldo caldo con cala
luna proprio incredibile ma non toccano
temi che ho avuto alla ryanair è perché
sono sono complicati di saltare proprio
nell'ultimo in questi perché chiusura il
distanziamento di blocchi maledetto
questo è che quando far cagate e non le
ho fatte incredibilmente sono sorpreso
di me stesso perfetto ok amiche c'è
l'ultimo che è difficilissima attenzione
road ma l'hai fatto e lo aspetta proprio
lui come la chiude allora mi sono
spaventato perché ero talmente lancero
talmente lanciato che ho detto vabbè
continuo per il caso caldo
ero troppo lanciato le stazioni fermo
muoio io sono bravo charlie vederci ai
muesly in quella in silico infatti non
capivo ok darvi che noa spesso male
aiuto non ha aiutato e quindi di aprirlo
e mentre che il sud per si chiude pare
il farm anni apre menu nel mentre è
appunto di chiuso per spostarmi con la
tecnica non cambiare i settaggi perché
io c'ho la meglio mettere il menu sulla
ed è sì io sono nato quando saltavo
quando saltavo mi si apriva almeno mi
giravo tolgo dalla locale del resto
michela cavolata maraga ok cielo
bravissimo il resto con era non era
facile non o per nulla questa è una
cagata incredibile in mano proprio però
quello che quello di prima 9 consenso
gli alieni bravissimo fin qui scusami ma
li po di qua un carnet mera c'è un muro
60 ma vai a cagare
lo so che conosco meglio di testi cosi
mannaia togliti maledetto schifoso ve lo
so io me lo sai
non devi scendere da titolare di fare
così guarda già è fortissimo
ayas e maledetto velate ha fatto fare un
tappino ha tirato un pugno che è entrato
john cena è ok
loris ha detto il menù è normale sono
cose lo fa solo 44 vedi che mi si apre
questo caso di menu ho fatto l'ho
cambiato di madonna lo tolgo subito
famiglia ma questo schifo di via
callegari e se avete capito perché ho
tolto dal controllo al menu paula è
perché non aveva senso mannaia me guarda
che mi sia per il menù per visiterà
aprile il menu proprio lui 36 proprio
lui ad onna ragazzi sono veramente
troppo orgoglioso di mezzo secondo anche
di chi sta andando avanti nei prossimi
ma stai fermo tavolette prove ma aspetta
mi hai africana nel calcio ci stanno
credendo all'ultimo esatto lo slime più
fine
esattamente amiche esattamente come
appena detto che devo andare dic e
arrivato brave scendi un ok allora qua e
lasko teca quale di fare tutto il giro
come l'altro teca e di fare tutto il
giro e savi e salire su sta roba di
acqua marina però non capitano bisogna
andare dopo ma c'è un caso rosso
seconda e poi veltro cromie c'è un
quadretto così c'è un cartello scritto
camier quindi arrivo arrivo mi piaci
pato ma un attimo o c'è un po al cui
interno vieni vieni ieri vi voglio bene
spesso ti aspetto un pilota bravo ciao e
arrivederci
oddio santo benedetto solo dovevo fare
adesso non lo voglio fare
ecco ma come fai ma non devi fare i
barbari non lo ri che non hai un neurone
devi andare a sinistra
però non si può fare difficilissimo però
il ma noi sì alzando e credo di sì
perché non c'è il senso va bene un sito
facendo aspetta feto scherzavano non si
sa fare così non si apriva ma no ma no
anche secondo me si deve fare quei due
amiche si sa fare così perché però se sì
cosa si deve fare
scusami allora tecnicamente dovesse fare
qui sopra aspetta facciamo così punto ha
capito a cacchio cero si fa chiamare
questa cosa qua più gravi in usa i morti
niente sapevo nice
e va bene non ci arriveremo mai su anno
ma ci capisce qualcosa sbagliano
soffitto che c'è un rumore strano ogni
volta mi becco lo slide
ok adesso ha fatto anche male perché
vado oltre
ma ce l'ho fatta sono forte e sono
uscito livello 37 i ragazzi questo era
il video di crude di magra falcons amico
pietre grazie ha partecipato al video di
mike per cui mi raccomando ragazzi
schieri lasciato mi piace un commento e
noi dopo un bacino ci vediamo al
prossimo i ragazzi
[Musica]